halla dies wieder einmal ran und heute
machen wir cocktails und wir haben
nämlich eine special zutat die wir in
diesem kopf rein machen willst geben
denn es ist ja ein halloween cocktail
also da muss man definitiv kürzer
ich habe einfach ein knipser aus kürbis
gemacht und zwar muss einfach ein kürbis
klein schneiden in den ofen packen und
dann pürieren
[Musik]
unabhängig voneinander in supermarkt
gegangen mussten uns die zutaten muss
und die zeigen wir uns ja ja ja ja also
erstmal den alkohol schlecht als starter
1 ist natürlich mein lag gegen zwölf
euro
vanille kirche ich habe mich ihn wahr
sind und sich auch ein stück sein magst
du nicht auch hier noch unterwegs war
kam das aus kolumbien und ein kleiner
kürbis du machst es den brink nicht
darin bestehen das ist echt gemein
ja du hast wirklich angekommen bist du
hast den gebrauchtkauf für das pps ist
da mein für das jetzt auch gesteckt
doch ich war aber kann ich den druck
machst du den bawag alter mann der weiß
dass wir den gleichen tag einen kalten
nachgedacht auch mirella die gleiche
idee hat wie ich und dann dachte ich so
das wird aber mir ja auch denken
natürlich wird's etwas anderes machen
wir nicht auch hierhin und gemerkt
unkreativen und kreative genau im
gleichen masse bis moment kelly new quay
faktor vier
eine kleister und wenn sie uns geben
dann bleiben wir hier leben
das ist ein spruch wenn man sagt wenn du
diese schecks nicht denkt man ganz kurz
nach hier mich hier nicht ja und hier
nicht dritter klub so jetzt auch ein
taschenmesser mit nützlichen dingen geht
gar nichts
leute ihr wisst gar nichts
meine milch und zimt erhitzen gerade die
verknüpfung der erfindung meines lebens
geschaffen oder ich hab schon farben
stärkstes meinen kaffee schmeckt es sind
weiß ich es richtig machen ja schlagen
derzeit ein wirken noch nichts gemacht
außer diesen kürbis wenn es am ende was
drin bitten wir so viel wein cocktails
und kürbis gemacht und einmal im café
machen ja obwohl kein zu trinken sagt
bloß gemacht haben eine doch
verschiedene getränke
irgendwas schon drin ich mit vanille
sirup reihe jetzt kommt ein böllerschuss
die curlerinnen 40 nach irgendwie körper
mit softair waffe warnt jetzt
professionell durch hektoliter 43
natürlich nicht gerade toll dass ich
nicht reden aber ich wohne ich habe am
kaffeetisch und wird in meinem leben mit
sich tragen
man sieht ja gar nichts von einem drink
plain hallo leute
[Gelächter]
wow
mit unserem wettbewerb gehen würde
das ist mein training in einer kleinen
kürbis ich nenne ihn psl mit schuss ist
kommt es halt leider von starbucks
geklaut ist der hübsche das mag ich lag
das ist ein 08 15 kürbiskopf freund ich
nenne ihnen den durchfall wenn der akku
sind ja stimmt du hast ja gesagt da ist
der einzige der so richtig gruselig ist
ich habe laktose-intoleranz deswegen
kriegt davon durchfall und da etwas
gruselige gab faktor das ist erzählt und
ich habe hier sehr gemacht stellt euch
einfach vor es gibt kein pilz sei
schrecklich und wann hattest du zu
deinem sagen dass champagner tim burton
group und tourist board und wiederum
habe ich nur umgebunden für all die
leute die sich an halloween erhängen als
geister zurückkommen und das ist eine
sozial ist oder
1000 post- happy halloween als richtig
lecker um eine aufwertung richtig
scheiße ist halloween ist auch richtig
lecker oder einer pid sind aber der wahl
als mit meiner lecker lecker noch nie so
schlecht das macht man auch so hier
schön so schlimm ist nicht der
ballermann etwas aberglaube ich gewonnen
das ist zugleich ein poker variante ist
es die lecker schmecken und das ist für
alle die sich denken ich würde sagen
dann wir haben in verschiedenen
kategorien gewohnt nein das ist
halloween vanessa hat grund also war es
schmeckt am besten beinahe sieht am
besten aus
hallo weil sie mich mal an die terra
xpress ist das einfach cool du bist wenn
du so auf der party steht bei zufalls so
stark ist er jetzt auch die mutter so
dass ihr euch rein falls sie sind viel
stärker
wisst ihr was leute ich glaube nicht
dass wir alle gewonnen
wenn ihr lager allerdings seid ja was
stimmt glücklichen momente an wert
gewonnen haben alkohol gemischt und
daran liebe kinder
gute nacht geht doch
in kanäle und abonniert diese kanäle und
schaut euch videos an bei der wir sind
lustig können wir alle so gut gepasst zu
drei jahren können hier schnell